e
e e
open the
meeting of the special committee on the
Family Division of the circuit court and
our purpose today is to look at the
final report and make a decision on it
let me give you my opening intro at the
end of which maybe you'll have some
things to ask or things to say this big
document um which is kind of what we did
Plus
several items that were submitted to us
this big document was emailed to you
yesterday
afternoon in the final report about 95%
of this was already
approved uh one part of it the end of
last year uh the rest of it not too long
ago this
year the vice chair gave us a schedule A
Week Ago which I accepted and a few
things happened during this past
week uh representative long suggested
something be included about the time he
was sending that it occurred to me too
great minds think alike so that should
be in my opening remarks in the
report uh I asked representative Greg to
supply a date on uh a meeting and she
did that uh a few subcommittee reports
were partially Rewritten to update for
example my report on Rules of Evidence
was accurate when it was accepted last
year but subsequent to that some things
happened in the Judiciary and that
needed to be mentioned so that my report
would be up to dat I think one other
report was about the same the question
was about the items that were submitted
to
us and there are a lot of
items what of these should be in the
report no suggestions were made to me
specifically about this report or that
report so our clerk who has been the
repository of all the stuff uh suggested
several I said do not want anything that
was primarily an angry criticism of the
court in general or naming a judge in
particular it was not helpful it was not
appropriate but thoughts ideas
suggestions facts comparisons would be
we
um centered on several and that is in
the second half of your
document there's a lot more and arguably
some might suggest we add this one or
take that one out we're not going to be
doing that today if that were the case
it would have been submitted to me over
the
weekend however when I was
appointed chairman of this special
committee I went through the very thick
file of previous times when the family
court was the
subject and anyone who wishes to do a
deep dive can uh
contact our committee assistants who um
will readily make those things available
there's a lot of stuff if somebody wants
to do a deep dive or if this uh special
committee is reconstituted some years
down the
road um arguably this or that could have
been
added when I was working on my doctoral
dissertation at Boston University the
dean pulled several of us aside and said
turn in your dissertations please uh
there's a deadline and we all said but
there's another footnote I wish to add
and there's another person I want to
talk to and he said this could go on
indefinitely he said as a result
sometimes people don't get the thing
turned in and that's the worst
dissertation the one that has never
turned in so same kind of a
thing yesterday a member of this
committee
asked if a couple of other things could
be added and I said no and the person
who asked that question was me because I
said oh my gosh we should have that in
there well the rules were get it done by
the weekend because we have to finalize
it and get it out the door so I said no
to me on
that maybe this special committee will
be Reed the report does not ask us to
vote on that but it does mention the
fact that some people here think it
could be it might be the reason is we
have established a good working
relationship with the
Judiciary and as a result we're able to
successfully pick some loow hanging
fruit but there's fruit a little bit
further up the tree and maybe that can
be addressed given our relation ship
with the
Judiciary that will be obviously up to
whomever is the speaker next year and
maybe that speaker is the same one maybe
that speaker is a different one but it
would be that speaker to listen to the
suggestions of some of us if we want
this committee
reconstituted if that's the case some of
the items that didn't make the cut such
as the two things I said no to coming
from me yesterday might just be put into
that next report so what we're going to
do today is look at
errors is are there errors of fact in
anything in the
report because they should be corrected
and I was overhearing a conversation um
before we get going that there might be
at least one error of fact so that's my
opening Salvo if anyone has a response
or anyone wants to dive in uh just uh
has to be recognized
representative
katab thank you Mr chairman I just um
had two like very minor clerical things
I assume if we kind of put those into
red lines that clerical things can be um
modified would that be okay if it's an
era of fact yes I don't want open up the
idea of let's add this let's add that or
it's an unending thing nope it's so it's
just um uh judge Luna's name was spelled
incorrectly it should have a u in there
where are we that is on
page
just now this is in the sorry that's on
the last page of the staple the last
page of the stap in the last paragraph
it just it's missing a u at the end
I don't see where you are right here I
see where you
are uh okay uh does everyone see where
she is and she asks if we can spell the
the judge correctly and you have that
one do
you okay good thank you um we'll throw
that in the motion to accept
with allowed changes any
objection um it just needs a u at the
end of the name
thank
you l u n e Au U okay and then there's
one any I don't see any objection to
that being part of our final motion go
ahead and then there's just one minor
missing Dash the rest have dashes just
consistency those are the only two
things missing a dash a hyphen H yeah
yeah so the rest have hyphens some new
laws this is under the document some new
laws passed
which is in here
somewhere and I don't see it
yet I don't see it but okay some new
laws passed this is this is a very minor
point but after HB A6 there is a hyphen
a dash and after HB 1564 there is and
there isn't one after HB 1005 any
objections to that you know that the we
do want to keep the punctuation police
at
Bay okay no objection to that anything
else that anybody sees that is a typo or
error of fact
any other comments that anyone wishes to
make representative
McBeth I just appreciate the the work
that's been done this past week and the
energy that was went into it to try to
bring this up to where everybody would
be happy with it thank
you and while I was surprised at what my
vice chair gave me last week I came to
see the sense of it it was good to have
this additional week just to make sure I
was working under the assumption that
this was like a um interim study report
which was due last week and when I was
informed that oh no it is not uh that
did give us the week and it did give
everybody a chance to get anything in
that he or she wish to have come in so
in retrospect I think this was um this
was a good thing we did as so thank
you I want to thank the committee we
worked well as a place in my opening
remarks where I said when I was
appointing subcommittees
I didn't think to balance them in terms
of party because we weren't acting in a
partisan fashion we were just want
wanting to make some helpful changes
with the Judiciary working with us I
think the attitude of everyone was to
let's work together and uh I think we
did and thank you to the Judiciary
um well nothing
else are we ready to
vote uh for the record to note that
representative Deborah D Simone from
children family law is sitting in for
representative ball also from that
committee I didn't know if we could do
this this is a special committee so I
called the speaker's office and they
said yes and they made the appointment
so just for the record um desimoni and
for ball and I would like to move the
acceptance of this report do I have a
second representative
Greg also known as our stealth weapon
you know when you get assigned to a
special committee the job gets done
before your special committee can even
convene because they listen to you and
they said what a great idea let's go do
that and you know you're two for two on
this so uh thank you so that's why I was
hoping you would be the second for it
all right it's been moved and seconded
to accept the report with the grammar
and spelling changes motion by the chair
second by representative
Greg would the clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson yes Vice chairman
Smith
no representative Lynn yes
representative Greg representative D
Simone yes representative l
not here not
here um representative cab votes yes
representative long yes representative
McMahon yes representative McBeth
yes motion passes 8 to1 is it 8
to1 it's 8
to1 thank you
andless anyone has a final comment
we're Jour rip it didn't no
no oh good
okay thank you everyone